you look 24 but your mind seems older so
that's that's awesome and what do you
think that perspective comes from I I've
had a really uh I feel like I've lived a
lot I I've had the best of both worlds
really uh I went to public school and I
I did the whole acting thing as a kid
and I got to live in different countries
and I don't talk to a lot of people meet
a lot of people and I I've really really
great parents and I think she was just
the environment being being able to
travel so much being able to meet so
many people and have a lot of
experiences just give them giving me a
perspective but I mean there's always I
I don't you know look at myself and be
like oh wow I'm wise I really think
there's a lot I could learn and there's
you know a lot of things I could prove
about me and improve upon and and and
try to expand and try to learn but I
don't know it's just it's just
interesting growing up and kind of
having a life in the industry and then a
total totally different private life if
there was another actor that was around
your age that is like obsessed with the
industry and they and they're almost
similar to some of these characters that
are in limelight and they asked you for
advice what would you tell them in terms
of like you know have a hobby do other
things try to get out of I would to be
completely honest I'd say you know what
it's easy to find yourself falling into
that you know I've been guilty that
before where I'm like well I'm Way too
focused on what other people think about
me what I need to be doing right now
where I guess I would just say live in
the moment you know if I'm 24 years old
I still got to remember that and I still
got to remember to have fun with my life
and hang out with my friends and not be
like what's next what's next what am i
doing next push harder you can do better
you got to have that certain element but
you also got to be a human and not not
an industry robot and I think it would
be just just live in the moment I think
that'd be my advice
you